I okay so we Donald Trump arrives in
Poland buses of supporters are there to
welcome him he gives a news conference
earlier today and at that news
conference Donald Trump said Russia was
most likely behind the hacking of the
2016 presidential election ah good he
agrees with the intelligence community
the intelligence communities of the
United States and many other countries
perfect great news but Donald Trump
couldn't stop there he added that nobody
really knows whether Russia was the only
country responsible okay so this is a
quote from Donald Trump in Poland when
he was asked whether Russia meddled in
the 2016 US election he said I think it
was Russia and it could have been other
people in other countries nobody really
knows nobody really knows for sure this
is a great example of a logical fallacy
and it can sometimes be a clever trick
at least it's clever in its usage
because a lot of trumpets are falling
for it and this is an argument from
ignorance sometimes you see an argument
from ignorance presented as a negative
proof this is when you claim something
could be true merely because it's not
been disproven and sometimes you'll hear
people say you can't prove a negative
now that's not actually true in
mathematics you can prove negatives you
can prove that I don't know certain
circumstances don't lead to a particular
solution for example in science you can
prove negative so it's wrong to say you
can never prove a negative sometimes you
can but in these types of situations
that we're talking about the fact that
we haven't disproven that other
countries worked with Russia would not
be a reasonable reason for people to
think that Russia did work with other
countries and that other countries did
interfere with the 2016 American
presidential election this we don't know
for sure thing
is like saying listen the last time Pat
was on camera just a couple minutes ago
we don't know for sure that I didn't do
two back flips and then really quickly
sit back down in my chair before the
camera came back to me we don't know
that for sure well yeah I mean that's
true I
I have not presented any evidence that I
didn't do two back flips while Pat spoke
but that's not a case for believing that
I did the back flips right I think the
burden of proof is then on you to
support your claim whatever that may be
you know I think when it comes to this
Russia story there's multiple steps and
as you go down the line maybe you are
able to criticize the validity of them
so you know number one Russia meddled in
the u.s. presidential election seventeen
of our intelligence agencies even Donald
Trump said this is what's going on then
you have number two which is that they
meddled specifically to help Trump then
you start getting into what we're
investigating did any members of the
Trump campaign collude with the Russians
or did Donald Trump know and was
personally involved that stuff we don't
know about that and you have every right
to be skeptical though no doubt about it
but the problem is nobody really knows
implies that it's just as likely that
other countries meddled in the election
as it is that it was just Russia and the
reality is as Pat is pointing out that
the Chiefs of all major intelligence
agencies the Senate which was briefed on
this everyone who actually followed the
reporting Russia mounted a major attack
on the 2016 election and there is not
positive evidence that other countries
participated nobody really knows is by
implication a drastic distortion and the
saddest part of it and this is really
where we're really coming up against it
here Pat is that lots of trumpets fall
for it and they believe it and they fall
for it hook line and sinker and and part
of this is why I am skeptical that what
we're seeing from Trump the lack of
accomplishments the constant lies and
distortions if we had a sort of normal
informed electorate open to being
influenced by empirical realities I
would say oh my god this guy is going to
be taken down you could possibly last
but when you think as I said yesterday
of what got Trump into office in the
first place and we didn't consider the
reality that Trump is don't care about
facts what they care about is for
example liberals being angry because
Trump is in the White House why is it
going to make a difference if Trump lies
or distorts or accomplishes nothing
they've won already merely by angering
liberals as they see it and they're able
to defend their position so easily
because if you show say a news report
they can just call it this' or if you
give them an intelligence official you
can say that they're a political hack so
it's very easy to do that mental
gymnastics it's kind of actually like
what Peter Boghossian describes his
Doc's a stick closure which is you've
got a closed loop right this is sort of
like why our religious beliefs so hard
to get people out of in many cases well
because when they start to question it
they go to their clergy and they say I'm
doubting the existence of God and they
say oh you know what you've got to read
your Bible
you've got to read your Bible and then
you'll figure it out it is a closed loop
if you don't have any external influence
that you take seriously that impacts
your understanding of the world it's
almost impossible for you to ever change
your perspective and that's what we're
experiencing here discuss this with us
on our reddit discussion forum david
pakman.com slash read it we'll take a
break and then I will interview the mega
bestselling author Ben Mezrich looking
forward to that today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or roku box and
then use your mobile phone as the
controller you can play as many games as
you want for one monthly fee and if you
find some games you want to keep you can
buy them for a low used price never with
due dates or late fees and our audience
can get a 30-day free trial at Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included no contracts and you
can also stream the games I think I
mentioned that you can also rent games
through the mobile app get a free 30 day
trial for david pakman show viewers and
listeners and support our show at
Gamefly offer.com forward slash TDP s